there are days when you wake up and you
feel so horrible that the only thing
that will make you feel better is more
alcohol and that's when you're in the
death spin she's covered some of the
biggest stories of our time
I'm Elizabeth Vargas and Baghdad but off
camera Elizabeth Vargas had a kind of
double life the mother of two suffered
from crippling anxiety and alcoholism I
mean I remember anchoring the evening
news and if you watch carefully at the
beginning of every newscast you will see
me lean in and I grip the desk with my
right hand and on my left hand which I'm
holding my pen I'm taking my engagement
ring and I'm digging the edge' dn't of
my thumb Elizabeth who says she's been
sober now for two years opens up about
it all in her new memoir between Bret's
she's also sitting down with Diane
Sawyer for tomorrow night's 20/20 we all
do everything we can today that tomorrow
we won't pick up a drink but we really
only have today Elizabeth suffered
blackouts and went to rehab four times
but she says it was a moment during a
vacation with her son that still haunts
her I was drinking and sleeping and I do
vividly remember like one afternoon Sam
standing by that my head in the bed and
say mommy when are you gonna get up and
I remember I could smell the sunscreen
and I could feel the heat from his
little body because he just come in from
the beach and you know I would die for
my children Diane but I couldn't stop
drinking for my children I don't know if
I will ever forgive myself for hurting
them with my drinking at